[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight back in January we first
reported on this show about what we
described then is a serious viral
outbreak that appeared to be rising from
a city called Wuhan in eastern China at
the time the outbreak sounded ominous
and potentially important but still very
far away today less than two months
later the Chinese corona virus is
officially a national emergency here in
the United States the president
announced that this afternoon at a press
conference in the Rose Garden to unleash
the full power of the federal government
that this effort today I am officially
declaring a national emergency
presidential message designed to both
check the spread of the virus and to
help the country recover and certainly
weather the economic disruption that's
causing the president's state of
emergency declaration freeze up fifty
billion dollars to battle the pandemic
regulations governing the length of
hospital stays will be waived most
visits to nursing homes will be
suspended the president also announced a
total freeze on interest payments on the
nation's 1.5 trillion in federal student
loans no more payments for a while he
said the government will purchase
billions of barrels of oil for the
Strategic ProLiant Petroleum Reserve
we're gonna fill it to the top he said
then in response to an adequate testing
across the country subject that's gotten
quite a bit of attention he announced a
new initiative to open drive-through
testing facilities the goal is for
individuals to be able to drive up and
be swabbed without having to leave your
car what more on the problems with
testing for the virus in just a minute
the president's announcement today
seemed to calm markets a bit after
dropping 10 points yesterday the Dow
Jones Industrial Average rose by more
than 9% with most the gains coming after
the president spoke still across America
regular life is all but suspended right
now as you know well sporting events
concerts and plays are being canceled
for religious ceremonies the Mormon
Church stopped all services worldwide at
this moment there are about 2200
confirmed Crono virus cases in the
United States there have been 48 deaths
those are not huge numbers in a country
of 320 million but there is reason
tonight to believe this could be the
beginning of something bigger in Italy
another 200
50 people died just today was the worst
day yet in Spain dozens are dying every
day countries are starting to take
dramatic measures in response to this
many are remembering the value of having
borders after having forgotten for quite
a while
Denmark Poland and the Czech Republic
have all closed themselves off from
outsiders and they're not likely to be
the last countries to do that in Iran
which could be the country hit hardest
of all globally the military has been
called out to clear the streets